[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei den damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen fünf meinungen
es ist der 21 kriegstag und eines steht
fest an diesen krieg dürfen wir uns im
namen der freiheit niemals gewöhnen was
sie heute wissen müssen die bundeswehr
verlinkt flugabwehrraketen der
ukrainische präsident selensky sagte vor
dem us-kongress zitat wir brauchen sie
jetzt russland blockiert 13 medien
websites und der ausschluss russlands
aus dem europarat ist jetzt fix doch wo
bleibt die regierungserklärung von olaf
scholz wer einen und die sanktion
unseren wohlstand kosten und wird sich
2015 wieder mal wieder passieren folgt
nach wir schaffen das nun erneut das
flüchtlings chaos darüber möchte ich
heute sprechen mit meinen gästen im
ukrainischen botschafter andrej melik
bild chefredakteur und bild tvb chef
claus strunz neben mir wie jeden abend
der bild vize paul ja für den a8 ost ist
der uns live aus kiew zu gescheit ist
schaltet ist und neben ihm cdu-politiker
und bundestagsabgeordneter philipp am
tor das konzept der sendung falls sie
zum ersten mal eingeschaltet haben
sollten was ich nicht hoffe es sehr
einfach jeder von uns hat ein thema
mitgebracht das ihn bewegt ärgert freut
oder schockiert wir haben
dementsprechend viel vor uns aber lassen
sie uns direkt mit paul ronzheimer
beginn der in kiew sitzt er jeden abend
dort für uns berichtet den ganzen tag
auf bild live und von dem wir auch
direkt erfahren können wie die lage vor
ort ist und welche these er heute abend
mit uns teilen möchte
ja vielen danke nena hier in kiew war
heute ausgangssperre auch nachmittags
wenn man befürchtet hatte dass es ein
angriff geben könnte deswegen hatte ich
zeit mich mit sören bartol
auseinanderzusetzen sie wären sören
bartol nicht kennen aber er ist
staatssekretär ist mitglied der
bundesregierung und er hat aus meiner
sicht einen unfassbaren tritt heute
geschrieben er hat geschrieben ich finde
diesen botschafter in anführungszeichen
mittlerweile unerträglich so verhält man
sich nicht gegenüber einem befreundeten
land und vor allem nicht gegenüber einem
kanzler einer bundesregierung die gerade
der ukraine gemeinsam mit dem deutschen
bundestag hilft sören bartol hat damit
den mann gemeint der dort heute in der
runde sitzen antrieb meldet aus meiner
sicht einer der mutigsten tatkräftigsten
und lautesten diplomaten und er hat
absolut recht laut zu sein die menschen
in der ukraine sterben und sören bartol
und die spd will dass man ihn
applaudiert aber das ist einfach nur
noch wahnsinn was da aus der spd kommt
denn was herr bad hall öffentlich sagt
hört man im hintergrund von vielen aus
der spd sich schimpfen über andere
männlich sie können es nicht ertragen
dass er schon vor monaten gefordert hat
dass dieses land waffen braucht zur
verteidigung dass dieses land verteidigt
werden muss ich finde kümmert euch
endlich mehr um gas kehrt als am anderen
ende gas kehrt damals meine ich den mann
ich würde es nicht aussprechen der mal
das höchste nicht das höchste aber der
mal das kanzleramt besetzt gehalten hat
hätte ich fast gesagt der kanzlerwahl
von deutschland gerhard schröder denn
man regt sich in der spd jetzt auch über
andere menschen aber ich höre gar nichts
mehr über gerd schröder also was ist
denn mit gerhard schröder warum ist ja
noch in der spd warum gibt es kein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ein mann
der weiter als kriegsverbrecher für ein
kriegsverbrecher arbeitet ich sage lasst
den ukrainischen botschafter in ruhe und
kümmert euch um gas gerd spd herr am tor
jedoch mal direkt die frage an sie
müsste sören bartol dafür zurücktreten
also ich gehöre jetzt nicht zu den
politikern
die sofort irgendwie in sekundenschnelle
rücktritte fordern aber ich finde es
eine absolute unverschämtheit und ich
weiß nicht herr botschafter ich finde es
gehört sich nicht nur dass er diesen
tweet lösch das ist meist mindest ich
finde er sollte sich auch persönlich bei
ihm entschuldigen ich hoffe dass er das
auf den weg gebracht hat ich finde es
ist eine absolute unverschämtheit ich
will das auch noch mal unterstreichen
es ist ja auch nicht ihre aufgabe
irgendwie der spd oder der regierung in
deutschland zu gefallen sondern die
interessen ihres landes hier zu
vertreten und das gehört auch dazu dass
nicht jeder politiker jetzt sind wir
alles uneingeschränkt teilt aber das was
der schirmbar toll gemacht hat ist finde
ich im ton völlig daneben liegend und
ich habe gehört dass hat für riesig
sorgen und debatten auch gesorgt völlig
zurecht ich meine ich will jetzt hier
nicht die dinge miteinander vergleichen
dabei ich erinnere mich an fälle des cdu
staatssekretäre und wegen ganz anderer
tweets zurückgetreten sind und ich finde
mit so einem das war eine emotion ist es
nicht getan denn es offenbart auch eine
geisteshaltung dahinter und ich finde
eine persönliche entschuldigung bei
ihnen wäre da das mindeste gewesen und
sie haben aber ehrlicherweise das
hinzugefügt gerade auch ganz andere
probleme als irgendwelche tweets von
dann völlig daneben liegen den spd
politikern aber es ist einfach
symptomatisch dafür dass das jedenfalls
keine gute haltung ist in der spd und
entscheiden dieser bundesregierung
tja also die einst als diplomat dazu
sagen um ehrlich zu sein habe ich diesen
träumen gar nicht verfolgen können weil
es gibt so viele davon und so viel zu
tun als nur einen twitter account von
herrn bartl hierzu zu verfolgen was da
läuft und für mich gilt nicht dass man
sich irgendwie entschuldigt dass das
dass das ist eigentlich nicht das was
man was man braucht man braucht jetzt
richtiges handeln und man braucht
wirklich das was wir erwarten von der
bundesregierung dass sie uns mal
zumindest besser verstehen dass man dass
man sich in unserer lage versucht
hineinzuversetzen zu begreifen was da
läuft nicht weiter so von von berlin
entfernt ein flugzeug flog seite und es
in gräueltaten jemanden seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg nicht mehr erlebten gesehen
hat und deswegen wie gesagt ja wir haben
das zur kenntnis genommen
also wenn wenn die regierung morgen da
was auf den weg bringen könnte also
ähnlich wie die amerikaner heute haut
erhalten dass an beiden eine
waffenlieferung gesetz unterschrieben
eine milliarde euro alleine dafür dass
die verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine
gestärkt wird und wir brauchen das das
ist das was wir benötigen und darum geht
es und nicht wie jetzt
das wasser manche regierungsmitglieder
da quasi im twitter
die zeit verbringen das ist für mich
also nicht zwei sondern drei ich ehrlich
gesagt aber eher wenig hier einmal die
rückfrage bei das hat ja auch paul
ronzheimer gerade aus kiew angesprochen
ist es seien symptomatisch für die spd
oder für andere politiker merken sie das
auch generell am politikern oder auch
bei bestimmten parteien wo sie sagen die
könnten micha ernster nehmen und b ist
der ton nicht richtig es geht nicht um
mich persönlichen und auch nicht um die
person eines botschafters es geht darum
dass das tier ukraine in einer
dramatischen lage sich befindet seit
genau 21 tagen und es geht darum dass
man dieser dramatik hier endlich erkennt
und auch dementsprechend handelt und
nicht nur eine zeitenwende einläutete
vor 16 17 tagen um danach gar nichts
geschickt also darum geht es und
natürlich wünscht man sich also mehr
verständnis aber auch mehr führungskraft
hier das vermissen viele ukraine die
gerade jetzt die mariupol wir haben
bilder gesehen ein theater wurde
zerbombte vielleicht viele opfer da
jetzt begraben und und man man man
schaut einfach weg oder man glaubt dass
dieser krieg jetzt so schnell wie
möglich zu ende geführt wird dass die
ukraine jetzt so kapitulation weil sie
nicht gezwungen wird vielleicht aber das
wird uns nahegelegt dass man sich lieber
ergeben sollte weil man diese
schrecklichen bilder hier in deutschland
nicht ertragen kann und das kann nicht
sein das kann nicht die politik sein ich
glaube auch dass immer noch dieses
gefühl gibt ich habe es gestern
irgendwo auch beschrieben gehört dass
das so ein spielfilm ist den man sich
anguckt also ich kann irgendwie
glücklich das gefühl nicht los dass es
für viele menschen doch immer noch so
eine fernseh ereignis ist das mit dem
eigenen wohnzimmer wenig zu tun hat wir
müssen aber vielleicht mal die
übersetzungsleistung noch verbessern
also dieses theater in mario pohl wäre
so als würde in münchen des
residenztheaters sich in die luft
fliegen das regierungsgebäude was ich
neulich gesehen aber eine der ersten
raketenangriff wäre so als wenn das
hamburger rathaus das rathaus am
rathausmarkt in hamburg fanden die luft
fliegt die bilder von menschen die vor
moan häusern stehen wäre als würde hier
in berlin oder in köln eine wohn zeile
einfach in die luft fliegen weil jemand
beschlossen hat ich terrorisiere euch
jetzt mit raketen das ist ja dass das
macht es nah und ich glaube dass wir das
wir alle in deutschland noch in sona in
seiner psyche
klemme sitzt von der viele glauben man
könne ist ausschließlich damit sich
daraus befreien dass man jetzt mit einer
unglaublichen welle der
hilfsbereitschaft sozusagen menschen aus
ihrem land willkommen heißt hier das ist
aber nur ein teil ein wichtiger teil der
andere teil der auf dem schauplatz in
der ukraine spielt ist deutlich
unterbelichtet und deshalb ist die
forderung die auch aus einer solchen
runde einfach immer und immer wieder
lauter tönen muss herr scholz bewegen
sie sich herr scholz tun sie was herr
scholz lasse sie der regierungserklärung
von vor einigen wochen taten folgen
liebe rot grüne man muss es nicht lassen
die gelben jetzt mal weg lieber rot
grüne ja ihr seid jetzt in der
verdammten situation in einer kriegszeit
in an der macht zu sein dann verhaltet
euch bitte auch so und dieser tweet auf
den wir da zurückkommen das glaube ich
dass das entscheidende die
dahinterstehende haltung nämlich der
mann geht uns auf die nasen er soll
jetzt mal ruhig sein und er soll uns
nicht dauernd an unsere eigenen fehler
und an unser eigenes versagen und an
unsere eigene vision rückständigkeit
beim liefern im wahrsten sinne das war
das erinnern das spricht daraus auch
eine große emotion und natürlich muss
sich der mann der den verfasst hat
mindestens entschuldigen entschuldigen
aber die handlung ist die entschuldigung
ist aber sozusagen das ist quasi doppelt
tod bei twitter also erst was schreiben
was einem ärger macht und sich dann dort
ein bisschen entschuldigen da muss schon
ich hoffe es ist ein brief auf dem weg
ein wenig und übrigens an alle ukraine
denn die hat er damit gleich mit
beleidigt ja irgendwann muss im übrigen
auch mal sagen die dahinterstehende
haltung jetzt zu sagen ich paraphrasiert
das mal so wie er zum ausdruck bringt
der herr meldet geht uns jetzt auf den
geist da muss ich mal sagen ich finde
wie sie sich diplomatisch nach häusern
und wie gefasst sie sind ist
ehrlicherweise mensch ich glaube
anerkennenswert wenn ich das vor augen
führe die vielen interviews sicher auch
von innen gesehen hat die gespräche wenn
sie berichtet haben wie das ist für ihre
familie den gast gast hat tagtäglich
erleben das muss man mal zum ausdruck
bringen ich finde was im moment in
deutschland ein problem ist und das hat
man heute gesehen ich meine wir haben
eine aktuelle stunde gehabt überhaupt
nicht zur primetime zur lage in der
ukraine
der bundeskanzler redet nicht er sitzt
auf der regierungsbank studiert seine
akten annalena baerbock redet dann und
hat im prinzip auch da werden
vorbereitete reden vorgetragen und ich
habe nicht den eindruck dass da die
emotionalität aufgegriffen wird die
jetzt nötig ist und wir erleben im
moment wenn ich den punkt machen darf so
ein stück weit so eine normalisierung
des krieges es ist ein stück war nur
dass viele jetzt sagen ja das ist jetzt
so wie der tägliche brennpunkt der nach
der tagesschau zu corona kann jetzt gibt
es seit das update was ist in der
ukraine und da kann ich sagen das ist
das hochgefährliche wir müssen es so wie
sie es gesagt habe nämlich genau
übersetzen und uns auch vor augen führen
was das heißt auch für unser land lassen
wir noch einmal zu kants heime in
abschalten das ist ja seine these und
ein paar partien haben wir noch nicht so
wirklich debattiert und das ist gas
gerhard wie du ihn genannt das was
können wir denn tun gegen ihn also was
sollte deutschland jetzt tun wie sollte
deutschland gegen energien und vor allem
jahr auch die spd seine eigene partei
ja das klingt jetzt so wahnsinnig rabiat
gegen kuhn ich glaube einfach wenn eine
spd sagt das ist alles so schlimm was
der ukrainische botschafter tun dann
frage ich mich doch moment mal also ihr
habt ja lange zu gast hat gehalten
eigentlich über all die jahre wo er
schon geld gescheffelt hat für wladimir
putin wo der schon das in seinem tresor
stecken konnte für die raketen die ja
gerade runter regnen lässt auf das land
in dem ich gerade bin und dann waren sie
plötzlich alle auch wieder ganz baff
mensch jetzt fette zu putin und dann hat
lars klingbeil der spd chef das fast
gelobt wo ich dachte moment mal ja okay
wenn er das hinkriegt gut und schön aber
man hatte schon die ganze zeit so das
gefühl das ist doch eher eine pr-aktion
und das hören wir hier
aus kreisen des präsidenten aber auch
andere menschen hat sich dazu klar
geäußert
und ich frage mich wann sagt jetzt die
spd also wenn du bist dann und dann
immer noch bei rosneft und bei gazprom
arbeitest dann streng wir ein
parteiausschlussverfahren an das kann
doch nicht sein dass alles sanktioniert
wird alle sanktioniert werden aber der
ehemalige bundeskanzler weiter kohle
scheffeln für wladimir putin und dieses
geld ausgegeben werden kann wenn man es
mal übersetzt für diese raketen die
hierunter regnen der und auch dass er
jetzt in diesen tagen das geld einnimmt
also ich bin jetzt nicht
absolut zuletzt also auf dem letzten
stand der details in welchen branchen
gazprom und die anderen bezahlen aber
die vorstellung dass jetzt irgendwie das
märz gehalt gekommen ist
deutlich fünfstellig in einer zeit in
der der absender sozusagen ein
kriegsherr und das brot und und diktator
ist das muss doch nimmt ich muss ich
muss ehrlich gestehen ich kann es
einfach nicht verstehen was mit gerhard
schröder los ist der muss verrückt
geworden sein also mir fällt auf dass
also der grat seines verrückt werden es
sozusagen sich in der in der menge der
instagram post seiner frau wieder findet
ihr also quasi jeden tag irgendwas
kostet und dann wieder löscht und es
wird auch immer und würde was sie da
macht er aber irgendwas muss mit dem
mann passiert sein denn es muss doch
einen sozialdemokraten und ich das würde
ich immer noch sagen das ist ja doch das
ist doch der sozialdemokrat gerhard
nachdem es gelungen war
sozialdemokratische ideen in die mitte
zu rücken mit sinn unter die leute der
muss doch jetzt sagen mein herz schlägt
noch so weit links dass ich mich
wenigstens von einem
kriegsverbrecher soweit distanziere ich
kann es macht mich eigentlich richtig
verrückt dass ich es nicht verstehe denn
ich fand den mann mit klasse und jetzt
finde ich ihnen im gleichen maße also
mindestens irritierend bis schrecklich
aber das katastrophal um das nur zu
sagen ist auch der umgang den die spd
schlägt damit ich meine das ist eine
wichtige natürliche und aufgebraucht
also die augen davor verschließen wir
werden mit ihm nicht reden was er da
gemacht hat und ich finde die
bundesregierung um das mal in den
details herauszuarbeiten
es ist eine unverschämte die sagen wir
wussten von der reise nichts wir haben
jetzt auch durch die berichterstattung
der bild zeitung erfahren dass die
personenschützer von gerhard schröder
bezahlt vom steuerzahler dass die mittel
russland waren und solche reisen sind an
der reihe und auch keiner
da es ist davon auszugehen dass ich
einen sicherheitsbeamten da bleiben und
die ministerin wird uns nicht sagen ob
sie es vorher wusste oder nicht wenigen
menschen wer kommen sowohl die emotionen
hier in dieser runde jedes mal wie
gerhard schröder das kann ich als
moderatorin feststellen wir kommen wir
jetzt zu einem anderen thema was uns
auch innenpolitisch nächsten jahre sehr
beschäftigen wird das sind die
flüchtlingsströme und damit zu claus
strunz ja also mit mit nachdenklichem
blick sehe ich die bilder der
flüchtlingsströme oder die strömung der
geflüchtete die menschen die in unser
land kommen und ich sehe mit großer
freude
die hilfsbereitschaft aber ich sehe doch
extrem sorgenvoll dass wir auch auf den
weg in ein neues 2015 sind was ich damit
meine ist es droht wieder wenn er nicht
sogar schon da ist der verlust der
kontrolle darüber wer eigentlich in
unserem land ist und das finde ich schon
außergewöhnlich quälend das aus den
ereignissen von 2015 und den jahren
danach wo wir uns stunden und tage und
monate lang darüber belehren lassen
mussten dass man in zukunft besser
vorbereitet ist auf die grossen
migrationsbewegungen
offensichtlich nichts gelernt und es
gibt keine registrierung an den grenzen
es gibt keinen expliziten schutz für
frauen und kinder es ist quasi freie
bahn für schleuser und menschenhändler
und alles funktioniert wieder nachdem
wird schon gut gehen prinzip hoffnung
und ich glaube dass es nicht gut gehen
wird weil wenn wir uns die zahlen
anschauen dann sehen wir am heutigen tag
das ungefähr 175 tausend menschen
erfasst sind polizeilich erfasst die
nach deutschland gekommen sind und 6
prozent davon sind keine ukraine
das steht jetzt schon fest 6 prozent von
175.000 sind rund 10.000 menschen sind
also jetzt bereits illegal ins land
gekommen und mehr noch als das das ist
gefährlich auf der einen seite wir
wissen viele von ihnen sind aus
nordafrika da gehen alle alarmlampen an
und wenn man dann nachrichten zur
kenntnis nehmen muss wie die aus
düsseldorf wo zwei männer aus tunesien
und nigeria die auch einen ukrainischen
pass hatten eine frau sexuell bedrängt
missbraucht haben dann müssen die
alarmlampen ja so hell leuchten wie nur
möglich es ist aber auch noch teuer denn
wenn 10.000 menschen illegal im land
sind und die allgemeine formel gilt dass
man für einen flüchtling im land
ungefähr 1000 euro pro monat für
unterkunft und essen rechnet dann ist es
ja schon mal 10.000 mal 1000 euro im
monat das sind 10 millionen euro ist
also gefährlich und teuer und deshalb
kann es nur eines geben bitte bitte
bitte grenzkontrollen so schnell wie
möglich klare registrierung wenn sich
rausstellt jemand ist kein ukraine bitte
ab nach hause das ist auch teil von
humanismus dass man sich um die um die
man sich kümmern muss wirklich kümmern
kann dadurch dass man die um die man
sich nicht kümmern muss auch wieder
wegschickt andernfalls mache ich mir die
sorge und das ist mein zentraler gedanke
von heute dass deutschland in die
geschichte eingeht als das land das
masken sünder und falschparker schärfer
bestraft und härter verfolgt als
illegale einwanderer und das wird uns
große probleme ja ich kann sagen einige
genau dieser sorgen haben wir heute im
bundestag zur sprache gebracht als die
innenministerin nancy faeser heute bei
der regierungsbefragung im bundestag war
und sie hat uns diese sorgen
größtenteils nicht ich will eine
einschränkung machen nicht glauben der
vergleich zu 2005 10 hat natürlich ein
paar schwierigkeiten das gute ist dass
ich zu 2015 unterscheidet ist die
europäische einigkeit und ich glaube
auch die situation der flüchtlinge der
ukrainer der europäer ist noch mal eine
andere als wir sie 2015 hatten aber
eines ist richtig das ist sozusagen nur
die kleine vorbemerkung richtig ist dass
wir im moment nicht hinreichend gut
kontrollieren die identitäten nicht
feststellen dass die innenministerin das
nicht mal als problem an erkennt ich
hätte ja verständnis dafür wenn man
jetzt sagen würde dieses und jenes ist
schwer aber wir erleben im moment und
das ist eine katastrophe hier in berlin
am hauptbahnhof wie wir gerade viele
frauen aus der ukraine hier billigend in
die hände schreiben von den falschen
leuten wie wir eine situation erleben
wie wir eben nicht den die möglichkeiten
die wir haben fokussieren auf die im
vordergrund sein sollten und wir leben
es ist keine planung da es gibt keinen
krisenstab kein flüchtlings koordinator
nichts und die innenministerin sieht das
nicht mehr als problem das halte ich für
den falschen aber ist also ich sehe
natürlich die unterschiede andere
vorzeichen
es ist auch ein anderer kultureller raum
aus dem die flüchtlinge kommen ich bin
aber bewusst einmal nicht auf diesen
punkt eingegangen weil es sind halt
menschen in afrika dagegen alle
alarmlampen an
naja du gut als ich meine herren die
domplatte auch erlebt und alles und wenn
ich meine wenn ich jetzt endlich alle
nicht klappen aber die na ja
entschuldigung nicht jedoch von der
wissenschaft einen richtigen soll jetzt
müssen das doch noch mal sortieren aus
nordafrika kommen
junge alleinreisende männer dem angriff
kannte ich vorher auch nicht und das ist
eine andere klientel da werden künftige
nobelpreisträger genauso dabei sein wie
menschen die gegen das immer in dem
teilweise als irak und nigeria eines war
tunesien und nigeria so und gelassen der
unterschied ist natürlich eine andere
kultur raum ein anderes verständnis von
zusammenleben und eine andere biographie
aber die analogie ist das aufgezählt
keine kontrolle keine registrierung es
ist uns eigentlich egal wer kommt es
wird schon gut gehen und es wird nicht
gut gehen es wird auch sozusagen unter
in der in der gruppe der geflüchteten zu
schwierigkeiten kommen das ist doch also
ich mir fällt fast nichts anderes ein
wie das wort schande dass man in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft eine 18 jährige
frau aus der ukraine
sozusagen ins nebenzimmer steckt zu zwei
männern
aus einem anderen kulturkreis das kann
doch nicht wirklich überzeugen durch
deutsche und das gibt es natürlich auch
es ist der offensichtliche punkte ist
wie viele aus nordafrika haben die jetzt
ich überspitzen das als eine art
trittbrettfahrer diese situation ein das
ist ja sogar sowie den hoxfelder müssen
wir halt wenn man eintaucht in die ist
es doch klar also wir machen mal nur das
planspiel wenn ich jetzt schleuser wäre
und mein geld damit verdienen würde
menschen aus afrika nach deutschland zu
bringen oder in die eu zu bringen machen
es noch weiter dann hätte ich doch jetzt
den jackpot die route ist doch klar hier
geht über die türkei und russland und
die ukraine dann braucht man zwei pässe
der treppenwitz schlechthin war doch
hier bleibe ich gelesen dass die beiden
die die beiden aus düsseldorf hatten
zwei pässe und wie kommen die ins land
die zeigen bei der ausreise natürlich
nicht ihren ukrainischen pass dann
müssten sie nämlich kämpfen sie zeigen
bei der ausreise ihren nigerianischen
passt und bei der einreise in
deutschland ihren ukrainischen und wenn
wir uns so reinlegen lassen von leuten
die unsere sozialsysteme ausnutzen
wollen dann sind wir doch in einer
vergleichbaren situation zu 2005 das
mich daher auf merkels ganze akzeptanz
der ukraine drin deswegen hat das denken
weil ich hoffe dass starr quasi nicht
mehr einholen und ich möchte noch eine
frage an die runde ständig gebe ich
direkt an herrn wenig was stroms nämlich
gerade angesprochen hat sind die
doppelpässe das heißt es sind menschen
haben ein ukrainisches pass und einem
anderen land das ist sie eigentlich zwei
staatsangehörigkeiten deswegen die frage
an sie herr männicke ich bin in dem
glauben aufgewachsen bei mir zu hause
dass alle menschen gleich sind und jetzt
stellt sich aber ehrlichen die hunde
auch in der diskussion die frage ist es
doch nicht so muss man ein richtiger
flüchtling sein ich möchte das beispiel
nicht verharmlosen was du auch gerade
aus düsseldorf angesprochen hast aber es
gibt ja auch menschen die beide pässe
haben dürfen die dann nicht ausreisen
stehen sie dazu als diplomat
also was für uns zählt ist diese warme
empfang denn meine landsleute hier nach
einer langen langen reise und nach nach
dem was sie erlebt haben hier erfahren
am hauptbahnhof an vielen anderen
bahnhöfen hier in deutschland und das
ist das was für uns in erster linie
zählt nämlich dass die menschen hier
wirklich mit offenen armen
ukraine in der ukraine sind vor allem
frauen und kinder die fliehen konnten
dass sie hier so warmherzig aufgenommen
werden und dass das was zählt natürlich
gibt es dann viele probleme und das was
wir jetzt erleben in unserem konsulat in
berlin da kommen hunderte menschen jeden
tag die gar keine reisedokumente
mitnehmen weil sie mussten so schnell
clean aus der ukraine das egal sie haben
vielleicht eine kopie ihres passes und
so das ist dann die sorgen die wir jetzt
haben hauptsache ist dass das man dass
diese dass diese solidarität nicht
nachlässt dann klar also 21 tage krieg
und wir sehen viele möglichkeiten oder
viele probleme jetzt bei der
koordination ich werde das thema auch
bei der innenministerin selbst
ansprechen und auch hier in der
senatsverwaltung damit man das besser
koordiniert weil die wollen nicht dass
diese menschen jetzt in die hände von
menschenhändlern
geraten das wäre das schlimmste was
ihnen noch zustoßen sollte nach nach
diesem greuel die sie erlebt haben ich
will doch mal was weil das wirklich das
so schön konkret mit den beiden passen
es ist ja nichts dagegen einzuwenden
dass austauschstudenten zwei pässe haben
dass menschen die in zwei ländern es
könnte aber genauso gut sein dass es ein
nigerianer und ein tunesier sind die
sich für fünf euro irgendwo einen
ukrainischen pass gekauft haben und ich
möchte dass wir bei der einreise
sicherstellen ob es die eine gruppe oder
die andere gruppe ist und der der einzig
gekauft hat für fünf euro kommt halt
nicht rein ganz einfach so würde ich es
in meinem eigenen haus aufmachen und
dass dieser staaten nicht in der lage
ist das zu unterscheiden und jetzt er
schon darüber nachdenkt wie wir heute
hören ob man nicht mit vokabeln arbeiten
kann also zb ob man gar nicht mehr
flüchtlinge sagt sondern vertriebener
und dann greifen bei vertriebenen
möglicherweise andere regeln also da
darf man nicht kontrollieren und so was
das allein sowas gedacht wird um das
eigene versagen wieder zu über gleis
erinnert mich an alles was wir bei
corona erlebt haben und es ist scheinbar
eine systemische frage der deutschen
politik der letzten zwei bis fünf jahre
und jetzt verlangt ja niemand dass man
irgendwie nur weil jemand aus nordafrika
kommt ein anderes recht anwenden die
austauschstudenten die in kiew unterwegs
sind und jedem aus kiew fliegen die
bekommen hier natürlich den status nach
dieser richtlinie der eu aber jetzt
brauchen wir doch keiner erzählen dass
jetzt hier lauter nordafrikanische
austauschstudenten aus der ukraine
fließe unter den reisenden muss man an
dieser stelle einfach nicht pauschal
diskriminiert aber das recht anwenden
weil diese schlimmen fälle des
asylmissbrauchs wenn die dann die presse
reagieren die rasante ist es so
verbindet die gesamt akzeptanz weil dann
sagen die leute die polygonale trennen
nicht zwischen denen die wirklich den
schutz brauchen jetzt vor putins raketen
fliehen und denen die trittbrettfahrer
auf diesem weg lassen sie uns doch alle
einmal super holzhammer nach abschalten
der ja nicht das erste mal als
kriegsreporter ist unterwegs ist dann
schon so vielen ländern war würde gerne
mal seine einschätzung zu der thematik
hören auch vielleicht zu klaus und
meinem kleinen disput eben
ehrlich gesagt halte ich mich da gerne
raus was in deutschland passiert das
sich seit sehr vielen wochen nicht weil
ich die ganze zeit aus der ukraine
berichte und nehmt es mir nicht übel
aber ich habe natürlich da vor allem die
perspektive derjenigen die hier
vertrieben werden habe da einfach großes
mitgefühl wenn man vor
völlig zerstörten häusern steht wenn man
erlebt wie hier jede nacht jeden morgen
diese reden gehen dann macht man keinen
unterschied erstmal zwischen ist es
jetzt ein austausch student oder ist das
ein ukrainer das sind menschen die
einfach fliehen nichtsdestotrotz kann
ich die kritik natürlich verstehen dass
man das grundsätzlich prüfen sollte nur
ich glaube
dass das so zu sagen wenn es passiert
also wenn sozusagen der strom da ist wie
jetzt dass es dann immer zu spät ist was
mich schon wundert ist dass wir nach
2015 offenbar keine verbesserung dieses
systems gebaut haben ja also was ist mit
der digitalisierung warum gibt es
sozusagen beim versuch auch ausweise zu
kontrollieren keine bessere methode was
ist mit den grenzkontrollen
da sehe ich keine veränderung oder
verbesserung und das deutet doch darauf
hin dass die politiker gedacht haben ja
2015 das wird sich schon nicht mehr
wiederholen ja und jetzt sehen wir wie
schnell sich etwas wiederholen kann und
es gibt ja politiker die sagen dass
dieser flüchtlingsstrom der schlimmste
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg oder der
größte seit dem zweiten weltkrieg werden
könnte und wieder noch vor sehr sehr
viel größeren problemen stehen werden
den nächsten wochen und monaten wenn
putin nicht aufhört hier zu bomben
die einschätzung war derweil die politik
übrigens auch wieder zu spät werden beim
film nachts vor ein paar wochen den
vorsitz der polizeigewerkschaft hier und
der da schon davor gewarnt wir alle noch
gesagt haben also ob die
flüchtlingsströme wirklich kommen hat
recht behalten aber nach deiner
diplomatischen antwort geben wir dann
weiter zu anderem einig und seinem thema
heute
ja also mir geht es darum dass das man
gerade in diesen schwierigen zeiten auch
mutige flagge zeigen könnte und sollte
ich meine in kiew die hauptstadt meine
heimatstadt
wurde immer noch nicht um zinggl nicht
angereist nicht besetzt die lage bleibt
sehr dramatische und dank dir und
anderen reporten aus meiner heimat
erfahren viele deutsche über das leid
der menschen tagtäglich und das was wir
gestern was viele meiner landsleute
erlebt haben war etwas ganz besonderes
nämlich eine reise von drei
regierungschefs aus polen aus tschechien
und auch slowenien mit einem zug nach
kiew um eben flagge zu zeigen haltung zu
zeigen manche haben hier in deutschland
gestern heute das sehr kritisch gesehen
und gesagt ja reine symbolpolitik
meine antwort ist kann sein aber gerade
um den menschen den mut zu geben wie
bleiben und das ist nicht nur der
präsident selensky oder der
bürgermeister von kiew klitschko sind
viele viele menschen sind über zwei
millionen tiere und heberinnen die
geblieben sind und die nicht bereit sind
ihre stadt aufzugeben deswegen es wäre
schön und wir haben schon vor
einigen tagen hier in diesem studio
darüber gesprochen es wäre schön dass
auch die deutschen mit dabei sind
vielleicht auch der bundeskanzler auch
mal schief besuchen könnte um einerseits
sich selbst diese zerstörungen anzusehen
und auch gefühl zu bekommen damit man
hier zu tun hat es ist keine krise es
ist wirklich der schlimmste krieg auf
dem europäischem boden seit
1945 und was wir erwarten wir erwarten
auch ein mutiges handeln der ampel
regierung um den menschen die bleiben zu
helfen und um der armee die kämpfe zu
helfen mit allem was notwendig ist das
wäre auf das gebot der stunde und damit
könnte man auch den menschen nun geben
dass wir nicht verlieren können dass wir
diesen krieg nicht
verlieren werden
also ich glaube dass man das ganz ganz
ganz ganz vielen ausrufezeichen versehen
muss und natürlich muss olaf scholz wenn
er es nicht schon getan hat seine
reiseplanung darauf einrichten und am
besten machte das zusammen mit
herrn makro der hat wahlkampf ich werde
jetzt mal zynisch dazu sagen der
süchtigen womöglich da auch noch also da
gibt es viele gründe und was mir an der
idee gefällt ist sozusagen die eines
menschlichen schutzschildes ja ja ich
glaube es ist die die die
intelligentesten und klügste art sich
jetzt zu verteidigen und ich will noch
mal erinnern dass hier auch aus der
ukraine schon eine einladung an den
papst vergangen ist und ich habe bisher
nicht gehört
was die antwort war die antwort kann
aber nur sein dass der papst dahin reist
wir stellen uns einmal für ein
romantisches
minütchen vor der papst sagt ich nehme
meine sommerresidenz in kiew das ist ein
iron dome also iron dome statt petersdom
das wäre ein zeichen denn dass wladimir
putin und die russische armee eine stadt
dem erdboden gleich macht das stand ja
immer mal in rhede als strategisches
ziel in der sozusagen der papst
residiert ist nahezu ausgeschlossen das
gleiche gilt
abgestuft auch für alle anderen deshalb
fand wenn man überlegt wie kann man
eigentlich als wahrscheinlich
militärisch unterlegen da ich will ihre
armeen und dem mut der ukraine nicht zu
nahe treten aber wahrscheinlich muss man
das einmal konstatieren als militärisch
unterlegen sich zu verteidigen
dass man am ende gewinnt oder jedenfalls
nicht untergeht finde ich dieses auf
persönliches engagement von wichtigen
personen gründende engagement sehr sehr
gut oder jetzt waren gleich alle
erschrecken wieso fährt eigentlich nicht
kreta dahin ja und sagt also das ist
zwar wichtig das weltklima noch wichtig
ist aber ne erde ohne krieg und deshalb
sollen alle jungen menschen dieser welt
auf sie gucken wie sie auf dem majdan
jetzt ein sit-in macht warum findet das
alles nicht statt warum ist das alles
nur quasi indirekt das soll jetzt mal
die ukraine erledigen und die nato unter
herbei da gibt es ja noch viel viel mehr
möglichkeiten und wenn von unserer runde
ein impuls ausgehen würde dass
wenigstens der bundeskanzler dahin fährt
werden wir schon schritt war mein der
urlaub schafft es dieser tage ja nicht
mal von der regierungsbank zum
rednerpult zu reisen im bundestag gleich
sagen leer war ich will noch mal
unterstreichen ich finde es war ein
unglaublich starkes zeichen der
ministerpräsident kann ja und ich will
auch noch mal sagen ich gehörte nie zu
denen da gab es ganz andere die im
bundestag immer den stab aufgebrochen
haben über den polnischen
ministerpräsidenten morawski der zeigt
jetzt eben auch wirklich eine klare
haltung an der stelle die
aufnahmebereitschaft die polen im moment
hat diese einsatzbereitschaft auch wie
die sich klarheit wahlgang mit langen
menschen die ins land kommen auch im
übrigen genau registrierung viele
administrative dinge funktionieren da
deutlich besser und da muss ich auch
sagen da gibt es manche die da über
polen und über unsere polnischen partner
glaube ich manches mal den stab
gebrochen haben die sich jetzt
richtigerweise korrigieren müssen ohne
dass da alle politikfelder wo man
überholt ohne fahrer jetzt aber geraten
und weise wieder so paternalistisch
gesprochen wo das hat mir nicht gefallen
und das verdient jetzt hohe anerkennung
und ich finde auch dass hat nichts
irgendwie mit einem pr thema zu tun
sondern das bild der lebenden
schutzschilde trifft es das ist echt ein
klares zeichen amputieren wollen mal
auch wenn ich so hart ausdrücken muss
beschreibt nochmal japan ich warte ich
eben ein ansprechendes
noch eine idee weil wir über so viele
figuren sprechen und nennt mich
vielleicht etwas obsessed aber das wäre
denn wenn der beste freund von wladimir
putin sogenannter
gasstrom recht kommt dass ein hotel
mitten am ball dann beziehen würde ich
glaube er könnte damit wirklich sein
image also da hätte ich auch kein
problem damit dass es ihm um pr aber man
fährt jetzt auch in meydan zieht da gibt
es auch ein schönes hotel das
hotel ukraine gläubig oder euro da kann
er auch seine frau mitnehmen die kann
auch tolle fotos von dort schießt
römerkastell sowie ein herrlicher blick
den habe ich schon häufiger wahrgenommen
dass wir also jetzt mal ohne witz also
wenn gerhard schröder
er sagt ich gehe nach kiew berlin auf
schröder noch höher als der brave
gesagt er wäre begleitet er wäre bereit
die an schröder zu begleiten das heißt
jesus angebot an gerhard schröder
henning würde sogar
paul nava den hallen der spd bleiben
das habe ich ja nicht zu entscheiden da
gibt es eine kommission die darüber
entscheiden muss das ist ja alles
geregelt wie wir wissen aber
mich würde noch interessieren eine frage
genau dazu an den herrn botschafter wie
würde denn olaf scholz jetzt nach kiew
kommt würde der auch mit der eisenbahn
fahren was glauben sie ist er der beste
weg und wie plant man aus deutschland
momentane reise hierher ja also ich
glaube hauptsache dass die entscheidung
fällt das der deutsche regierungschef
auch mal diese flagge zeigt und
vielleicht auch die worte benutzte
jemand hier in berlin im jahre 1948
gehört hat schaut auf diese stadt ja
diese stadt sie ist bedroht tag und
nacht sie wird beschossen
sie wird vergewaltigt jeden tag und
trotzdem steht diese start und ich
glaube wie man nach kiew gelangt das ist
eine andere sache am besten du dich mit
deutscher bahn bis zur grenze und dann
gibt es auch ukrainische bahn
wir haben immer noch als darlehen
wirklich sehr bequem reisen
wer also genau diese rede die er dann am
besten auch in der nähe des magens oder
wo auch immer hält schaut auf diese
stadt andere manager hätten sie das für
realistisch haben sich schon mal
vorgefühlt im kanzleramt nein aber ich
glaube das ist schon etwas was was man
manchmal braucht man braucht natürlich
vor allem diese unterstützung die die
menschen benötigen die jetzt ausbaden
müssen in schutz brauchen können in
kellern und da seit wochen aber man
braucht auch diese gesten ja gestern der
zuversicht dass dieser staat nicht
untergehen darf dass die ukraine nicht
untergehen darf und darum geht es heute
ich muss jetzt eine ganz kurze
unterbrechung leider aber danach geht es
ganz spannend weiter und wir reden
beispielsweise auch über die sanktionen
über lösungen und was sich deutschland
noch leisten kann bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine zuschauer
zurück weil viel nach acht meine gäste
heute abend der ukrainische botschafter
anderem eine neben mir tvb chef und bild
chefredakteur claus strunz an meiner
seite wie jeden abend gewann zweimal
live aus kiew und der cdu-politiker
bundestagsabgeordnete philipp abenteuer
um mit dem legen jetzt auch direkt los
härter was bewegt sie ja ich bin schon
sehr gespannt auf den donnerstag im
deutschen bundestag der ukrainische
präsident wohl otto mir selensky wird
sich an uns richten mit einer live video
schalte und die zentrale frage ist doch
dann natürlich wie reagiert der
bundeskanzler heraus hält ja eine
emotionale rede oder überhaupt
irgendeine rede oder gibt es eine
debatte zur ukraine
das absurde ist fehlanzeige
es folgt gar nichts diese ampel
koalition will tatsächlich nach der
ansprache von volume i see lenski die
debatte zur tagesordnung übergehen
lassen und über die impfpflicht
diskutieren im us-kongress macht man es
anders im europäischen parlament hat man
es anders gemacht und wir verlangen dass
der bundeskanzler im parlament eine
regierungserklärung abgibt wir haben
immer gesagt die bundeskanzlerin hat im
parlament da hat die opposition
gefordert dass eine regierungserklärung
abgibt wenn sie nur einmal über brüssel
fliegt und sie hat es auch gemacht nach
jedem eu-gipfel und jetzt sehen wir
scholz duckt sich weg und ich finde das
ist zum fremdschämen
wie könnt ihr die führungsstärke von
herr scholz aussehen
also ich glaube dass das wäre schon
angemessen wenn wenn wir jetzt diese
historische rede haben werden und dies
historisch nicht nur für uns sondern
auch für deutschland denn zum ersten mal
wird ein staatsoberhaupt
online vor den abgeordneten auftreten
eine rede halten ich glaube das wäre
schön dass man auch darauf reagiert im
anschluss vielleicht auch eine debatte
stattfindet und dass auch die regierung
eben den weg schildert also was was
geplant wird also was was die ampel
jetzt vor hatte um der ukraine zu helfen
also wir haben gehört die zeitenwende
wurde eingeläutet aber seitdem
gab es nicht viel was wir gespürt haben
und deswegen das glaube ich schon eine
eine wichtige botschaft aus berlin um
eben nicht nur
präsident sondern was was die menschen
in der ukraine erwartet werden das
glaube ich das wäre eine schöne gäste
man muss sich das mal vorstellen ich
wills nur noch mal unterstreichen die um
die empörung wir haben diesen krieg wird
seit 20 tagen die europa im
kriegszustand und seit der
regierungserklärung von scholz sitzt er
im parlament und sagt nichts den
diskutierten heute über die ukraine er
sitzt stoisch zuhört zuschickt annalena
baerbock vor und er
positioniert sich einfach nicht das
finde ich ist also unglaublich und das
geht auch völlig vorbei an den themen
die irgendwie die menschen zu hause
bewegen die europa bewegung und die
unser land bewegen müssten eigentlich
glaube wie diplomatisch ist alles gesagt
das geht gar nicht es müsste natürlich
die große rede des bundeskanzlers von
mir aus und oder der aussenministerin
sein die dazu bestellungen aber ich
überlege mir auch die ganze zeit würde
ich mir das versuche vorzustellen dieses
waghalsige
terminplanung da und den ablauf was
sendet das auch für ein signal sendet
auch das signal dass dieses parlament
und die regierung quasi sich total
anders verhalten als jeder normale
mensch sich verhalten würde wir stellen
uns mal vor es sind menschen in einer
freundin freundeskreis beim abendessen
und dann kommt sagen wir mal der
oberbürgermeister dazu der kommt dazu
und er spricht da und sagt etwas ganz
bedeutendes und das die ganze stadt von
interesse sondern geht er wieder und es
gibt keine gruppe kein esstisch kein
stammtisch keinen freundeskreis der dann
sagt auf wiedersehen machen sie es gut
und zu seinen alten themen von vorhin
zurückkehrt sondern natürlich wird man
sagen das war toll das war wichtig das
hat uns herausgefordert da wollen wir
mitmachen so sehen wir dass das würde
man ja schon als guter gastgeber
eigentlich erwarten also das verstößt
gegen alle guten regeln des
zusammenseins und ist politisch ein
unglaublicher fauxpas möglicherweise
wird noch um gedacht bis bis zu dem
moment und und olaf scholz bewegt sich
dann doch gegen das protokoll und gegen
die dinge auf eigenes mandat ans
rednerpult und sagt wir haben es aktiv
gefordert man hat es blockiert aber wenn
das in deshalb mehr drin ja es ist doch
absurd über die große ministerin hat
sich heute hingestellt und sagt manchmal
sei es besser zuzuhören als nur zu reden
ja natürlich werden wir alle gebannt
zuhören das werden emotionale worte
seien von melodie lenski aber dann nicht
in die diskussion zu gehen ist einfach
absurd und ich finde was aus sicht der
menschen nicht stimme dass auch vor wenn
in einer live übertragung im deutschen
fernsehen die leute sehen was präsident
seelands gesagt und dann wird das thema
impfpflicht ausgerechnet die impfpflicht
die diskussion über die mit der korona
politik wollen jetzt monatelang mit die
blut an hochgezogen darüber diskutieren
die abgeordnete dafür kann niemand
verständnis wir wollen hier einmal ein
paar runs einmal der uns live aus kiew
zugeschaltet mit den diskussionen rein
und paul meine frage sie direkt bei mir
im kopf entsteht ist ist es vielleicht
auch strategie ist es methodik der mit
wladimir putin vielleicht ja nicht noch
aggressiver wird also machen die das
feld im bundestag überlegt als sind frau
berbalk unter scholz vielleicht überlegt
und es soll genau das signal gesendet
werden was damit gesendet wird es wird
zugehört aber wir sagen nichts
ehrlich gesagt fällt es mir schwer bei
dieser bundesregierung momentan an
irgendeine große strategie zu glauben
die dahinter steckt wahrscheinlich hat
das tatsächlich er mit tran le sich kai
zu tun dass man da gar nicht dran
gedacht hatte dass das doch eine schöne
idee wäre dann eine debatte zu machen
und dann hat das die opposition erkannt
und dann wollte man wahrscheinlich nicht
nachgeben und sagen ja mensch der märz
hat und zwar meistens nicht recht aber
hat zwar meistens email verletzung aber
wenn wir diesmal diesmal schon so ich
glaube so einfach ist das auch finde
immer noch dass tatsächlich die art der
kommunikation von olaf scholz in dieser
krise wirklich ein problem darstellt
also man hat ja vorher immer gesagt toll
jetzt haben wir so ein kanzler der redet
genauso langweilig wie die kanzlerin so
und jetzt haben wir kanzler wo ich mich
manchmal frage ob er die leute wirklich
mit nimmt auch in dieser krise und ob er
wirklich einerseits denjenigen die
vielleicht sogar skeptisch oder dies
sicherlich gibt die skeptisch gegenüber
den sanktionen sind erklärt warum die
wichtig sind ein bundeskanzler der auch
erklärt was eigentlich in der spd los
war in den letzten jahren der auch mal
sagen kann seine partei hat große fehler
gemacht mir fehlt in der ukraine
ukraine krieg ein kanzler der
ehrlichkeit mit klaren worten klaren
ansagen an dem ich mich orientieren kann
das bürger und es gibt vielleicht noch
einen punkt also dem drängen der
opposition durch nachgeben ist
vielleicht tatsächlich angesichts der
größe des ereignisses ein bisschen zu
klein
von mir vorhin auch schon selber
eingeflogen aber vielleicht ist es eben
ein beredtes schweigen weil er wird sich
gefragt haben was soll ich dann
eigentlich sagen ja wenn mich jemand um
hilfe bittet kann ich ja schlecht danach
sagen kommt aber nicht
also der moment wenn selensky mit dem
ihm eigenen
positiven partners und dieser
überzeugungskraft und dieser rhetorik
der gewinnenden rhetorik in der
situation eine bitte äußert muss man ja
eigentlich sagen ja da kann man auch
nicht sagen hatte denken wir jetzt mal
darüber nach sondern dann muss man
eigentlich eine antwort geben und wenn
man keine antwort hat schweigt man
vielleicht lieber aber ich stelle mir
trotzdem die situation morgen vor wir
haben ein bundestagspräsidium jetzt
schon mal sehr sehr reduzierten bestand
sind jetzt corona bedingt nur fromm
göring eckardt und frau da ich glaube
frau göring-eckardt leitet dann morgen
früh die sitzung ich meine ohne der
jetzt despektierlich zu sein aber was
wir sind dann sagen herr präsident danke
für ihre worte wir wünschen ihnen alles
gute es ist also ist ja schon fast
galgenhumor aber ich finde das ist und
ohne unebenheiten
frau wird im zweifel noch sagen dass das
doch eigentlich ganz richtig ist was er
wladimir putin da sagt ja ganz so
schlimm die macht ihre amtsführung schon
ganz okay aber es doch auch absurd wenn
man sieht dann wie wie das läuft und was
das für ein signal auch an präsident
seelands geht man heute im us-kongress
ich habe es jetzt am rande der
bundestagssitzung nur in der
berichterstattung verfolgen können diese
leidenschaftliche debatte die nach
seiner adresse dort im kongress gefüllt
wurde das ist es wie man es erwartet und
dann einfach zu sagen vielen dank alles
gute guten weg und tagesordnung ist eine
peinlichkeit schäme ich mich wirklich in
der außenwirkung auch ich wir werden das
schon alle kameras voll draufhalten und
es dann noch entsprechend würdigen
hermann ob wir werden es würdigen bei
bild das versprechen wir ihnen denn
jetzt kommen wir zu einem thema der
werden sie bestimmt ganz böse auf mich
sein wenn ich weiß ich werde hier der
kunde dafür wenige punkte gewinn aber
ich muss es dennoch ansprechen und zwar
geht es um die sanktionen und mein thema
heute abend ist noch stärkere sanktionen
werden uns den wohlstand kosten die
sanktionen sind schon jetzt eine große
gefahr für unseren wohlstand unternehmen
drosseln die produktion weil sie sich
nicht mehr leisten kann diese
aufrechtzuerhalten
viele menschen müssen erneut kurzarbeit
weil aufträge fehlen und die energie
unbezahlbar geworden ist die wirtschaft
ist der motor dieses landes unseres
wohlstandes und dementsprechend das
ultimative gegenmittel gegen
gesellschaftliche spaltung der ost west
konflikt wird noch viele jahre
vermutlich jahrzehnte
und wenn ich es nicht schaffe andauern
zu dieser auseinandersetzung brauchen
wir eine starke wirtschaft und wir
brauchen wohlstand nur so können wir die
völker in russland und china von der
demokratie überzeugen ich finde alle
bislang und das ist mir sehr wichtig die
ukraine krieg beschlossenen sanktionen
richtig jede einzelne die bislang
beschlossen wurde ist richtig wir müssen
uns zur wehr setzen und sanktionen sind
ein probates mittel und die bisherigen
sanktionen werden wir alle gemeinsam
aushalten für die ukraine und für die
freiheit auch wenn sie die wirtschaft so
sehr treffen aber jetzt reicht es es
stört mich ungemein dass politiker und
journalisten immer höhere sanktionen
fordern ja am liebsten sofort das öl und
gas embargo ohne über die folgen für
unser land nachzudenken es sind genau
die berufsgruppen die von den sanktionen
nicht betroffen sein werden die
regierenden politiker haben wir den
amtseid versprochen schaden vom
deutschen volk abzuhalten ich weiß dass
es kein leichtes unterfangen ist die
ukraine in ihrem freiheitskampf zu
unterstützen und gleichzeitig das eigene
land vor allzugroßen wirtschaftlichen
schäden zu bewahren aber wir müssen es
versuchen ein öl und energie um wago
kann meiner meinung nach nicht die
lösung sein ich bin davon überzeugt noch
härtere sanktionen sind nicht der
richtige weg die bisherigen haben ihre
wirkungen noch lange nicht entfaltet und
putins krieg wird dadurch nicht
schneller enden aber wir werden
verlieren während americas öl industrie
profitiert und jetzt traue ich mich kaum
herr anzuschauen
ich glaube dass gerade die deutschen sie
haben das in der hand was sie gegenüber
herrn putin auch über nutzen könnten und
sollten und dass es diese abhängigkeit
die entstanden ist in den letzten
jahrzehnten der beiden koalitionen
vorher und jetzt müsste man auch diesen
hebel genau diesen hebel bis zu ende
auch ins spiel bringen dann wenn man die
sonne sind hart da haben sie recht in
der tat sie entfalten ihre wirkung zwar
nicht kurzfristig das ist auch wahr sie
können nicht gleichzeitig und sofort das
verhalten von herrn putin verändern aber
wenn man zb sich gedanken macht über ein
moratorium also ein monat lang
beschließt die abend bei der regierung
kein gas kein öl und keine kohle zu
beziehen als signal das heißt man könnte
einen monat überleben ja das ist das
wäre auch ein signal und das ist
vielleicht auch ein zwischenschritt zu
schauen vielleicht wird das schon diese
diesen effekt haben wo herr putin
schneller sich entscheidet auf den
verhandlungstisch oder zum
verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren und
wirklich über den frieden zu reden und
nicht nur vorzutäuschen also ja ich
glaube auch ich kenne in unserer
sanktionspolitik und sozusagen den
pfeilen im balco hin oder her auch diese
deutschen lust am immer alles
hundertprozentig machen natürlich kann
man so etwas in betracht ziehen und
damit eine eskalationsstufe die erste
eskalationsstufe scharf stellen ich
glaube aber anders als nena auch dass
man wenn man sich in einer so harten
auseinandersetzung einem krieg dafür
entschieden hat aus guten gründen nicht
militärisch in den einzutreten sondern
als waffe die sanktionen gewählt hat
dann muss man auch nach laden können
wenn sozusagen die erste salve nicht
reicht deswegen fürchte ich dass wer da
a sagt muss auch in der lage sein b
sagen zu können weil er sonst nicht
ernst genommen wird und ich finde auch
bei der sogenannten
und technisch gesprochen bepreisung der
sanktion lässt es sich schnell bemessen
was kostet es wenn wir einen bahnhof
hängen was hat das für auswirkungen auf
die wirtschaft wir müssen aber auch mit
einberechnen was heißt es für die
volkswirtschaft in deutschland und
europa wenn dieser krieg fortgesetzt
wird und deswegen finde ich an der
stelle wir machen es uns da oft zu
leicht und greifen so schnell nach den
preis barren dingen wir müssen in diese
kosten abwägung aber auch einstellen
welche folgen hat die fortsetzung des
crea hunter ich finde wir machen es uns
viel zu leicht und das ist ja industrie
also das öl und energie embargo ist
wirklich leicht so es ist auch leicht zu
folge hat dass niemand in der
pauschalität dem namen sondern wir haben
uns ja bewusst sozusagen für ein
abgestuftes system jetzt erstmal
entschieden und ich finde das ist immer
noch eine balance gewesen bei den jetzt
gewählten sanktionen und auch bei den
diskussionen die wir fortsetzen
aber es werden ja immer härtere
sanktionen gefordert das wird doch
während immer ein held aller kriege
geführt von wladimir putin gegen die uhr
über beide entlassen lassen lassen sie
uns einmal heran vorbei und wenn sie es
mir erklären können dann wäre ich in die
kamera sagen es tut mir leid nicht
fordere ist jetzt auch erklären sie mir
bitte wie soll der krieg beendet werden
wenn wir dieses öl und energie in bar
druck machen weil der punkt ist der da
wir werden es nicht mehr bekommen aber
china wird beziehen dadurch dass die
preise steigen kann russland
kompensieren ich glaube nicht dass wir
da mit putin aufhalten können ich sehe
nur wirtschaftlichen schaden hier werden
geschwächt aber ich sehe nicht dass
dieser krieg endet und dementsprechend
deswegen bin ich dagegen ja es wird
keine maßnahme dieser welt geben die den
krieg isoliert betrachtet beendet
sondern es geht um ein bündel und es
geht darum wie stark die
entschlossenheit ist die wir als
westliche welt gegen wladimir putin l
das noch alles muss nein heißt dass
nicht nur alles muss es geht geht es
geht im krieg im übrigen aus meiner
sicht auch nicht nur um moralismus und
es geht auch nicht nur um pragmatismus
sondern es geht darum dass wir für
unsere werte auch ernsthaft einstehen
und wir müssen deswegen schon auch
bereit sein kollateralschäden auch bei
uns selbst zu akzeptieren und wir müssen
deren legen collateral schaden haben ja
wir haben wir haben volkswirtschaftlich
haben wir alle den schaden davon und im
übrigen muss für uns auch klar sein dass
es um das maßnahmenbündel geht und wenn
wir jetzt schon putin zeigen in der
aktuellen situation ist uns dann die
eigene volkswirtschaft und nur weitere
einschränkungen ist uns näher als das
stoppen des krieges dann ist es das
falsche signal wir müssen das
ausbalancieren und müssen im übrigen
deswegen sagen wir sind wirtschaftlich
entschlossen russland noch weiter zu
isolieren wir sind militärisch
entschlossen gegen zu halten und
brauchen deswegen ein klares bündel
sozusagen auch an entschlossenheit das
heißt nicht null und eins das heißt
nicht sofort wirtschaftsembargo das
heißt nicht in den konflikt militärisch
eingreifen aber wir sollten jetzt nicht
zurückschrecken vor putin und müssen da
auch klare stärke zeigen wir geben
einmal super monsheimer live nach kiew
was er zu unserer diskussion sagt ich
glaube ich werde ganz schön was
abbekommen ist nach ich immer gerne hin
ich bin ehrlich gesagt relativ müde das
immer wieder zu erklären nicht einfach
um das wichtig ist aber ich akzeptiere
natürlich deine meinung und auch die von
allen teilnehmern und natürlich ist es
so dass wenn man gerade hier in kiel
sitzt das sehr sehr anders betrachtet
mein punkt ist wenn wir es nicht
schaffen putin in die schranken zu
weisen wenn wir es nicht schaffen hier
die freiheit der ukraine zu verteidigen
mit den ukrainern dann geht europa
verloren ich bin da sehr auf der seite
von herrn modewelt ski dem polnischen
regierungschef das so ähnlich gesagt hat
gestern und wenn wir es nicht mit waffen
erledigen wollen was wir nicht tun
wollen wir wollen nicht teil dieses
krieges sein wir wollen auch nicht
wirklich mit großen ansporn der ukraine
mit waffenlieferungen helfen wir tun
dass so ein bisschen halbherzig
überlassen das aber den amerikanern wir
wollen auch nicht dafür sorgen dass eine
flugverbotszone gibt na ja dann müssen
wir uns irgendwann mal entscheiden und
die sanktion die es bislang gibt das
sind die die wladimir putin ohnehin
eingepreist hat er hatte vielleicht
nicht eingepreist dass das militär so
marode und schlecht ist und dass alle so
viel angst haben dass keiner ihm die
wirklichen zustand dieses militärs
berichtet hat aber die sanktion den
bislang beschlossen sind die hat er alle
eingepreist und ich glaube über die muss
man dringend
hinweggehen mit dem ziel dass wladimir
putin noch stärker in die enge getrieben
wird und dass am ende ist eine
möglichkeit gibt dass er vielleicht
gestürzt wird oder aber dass sein
engstes umfeld ihn dazu bringt eine
abkehr dieser mörderischen politik zu
machen und damit paare haben wieder die
letzten worte unserer sendung gehört
dass es jeden abend unsere tradition
morgen abend sind wir wieder hier vielen
herzlichen dank an meine gäste andré
niklaus transparenz heime und philipp am
tor haben sie noch einen schönen abend
und lassen sie uns diesen krieg nicht
zur normalität werden lassen tschüss
[Musik]